I don't know if Biden's gonna be able to
last another debate dude they might
sneeze and fall apart dude imagine if
that was your grandpa yeah you know what
I mean you'd be like dude like there's
one through he's like this we're
supposed to shake someone's head it goes
like this
and then the other guy's like bro I'm
Secret Service
like go that way
[Music]
so we're gonna talk about something as a
blast from the past y'all didn't know
we'd be talking about this again we're
talking about nfts what are they coming
back I'm making a comeback no they're
hot oh they're not they're hot right now
no it's probably what you could buy it
now though when they're dead that's what
you gotta do quickly you gotta buy them
you gotta buy you gotta buy it what's up
with like somebody's just come out with
a [ __ ] collection are you talking
about the the Trope ones you gotta stop
reading articles so we can host and read
the articles every single time you've
been on a roll today dude I can't help
it
I got excited how much are board Apes
now I think that was good at what I was
gonna let me look it up yeah look at
what happened with that market because
if you are supposed to buy things when
they're down we're supposed to buy it
now how much are those [ __ ] I
mean she asked Andy he still got them
can they get can they go any Downer
though we've seen them go pretty damn
yeah floor price right now 69 eth and 69
eth as well that sounds like a lot less
than 100 000 maybe oh so it's still like
what were they what were they before
like half a million they could go up
there I remember like I think Eminem was
buying his for like 440 000 at the time
you know what I mean it's still like 70
Grandpa you gotta stop buying [ __ ] when
they're hot dude that's a problem so
Donald Trump today launched the uh
launched a collection of nft trading
cards that claim to come with real life
benefits for buyers including an invite
to a Gala dinner Donald Trump did this
WOW or even a meet and greet with the
former U.S president
um a lot of people are reacting to this
obviously uh both positive and negative
in weird ways they're selling for 99.00
piece on the polygon Network he
officially announced this on his truth
Social account sounds like a good deal
and when you buy one too you enter into
a sweepstakes to win certain perks is
Apple going to come back on Twitter like
did it he said he's not he said he's not
oh he's not yeah I feel like his account
is back so I think it's a good like
marketing like you said right so he
launched on truth and also he has to
compete against DeSantis who's pretty
much beating him in the polls right now
so he's doing whatever it needs to get
out yo what the [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
hilarious Trump and obviously his
glorious uh this is these are real
photos of this physique by the way he's
looking great nowadays guys he's in
shape have you guys seen that dance
video where he Moonwalks Is that real
what no
already sounds Facebook there's one
where he's dancing you got to watch him
damn he's like this guy moonwalking he's
just dancing it's like is that dance
video real you know how you know it's
real if his butt looks the same like his
body bro Trump dog dude Trump has a duck
body he's got a battle last maybe they
just superimpose his face on Christopher
Walken's dance video yeah he's going oh
that's why they should call him Donald
Duck Trump because his body's in the
shape of Donald Trump he does kind of
like a duck I know what you mean like he
hello he had a white in the middle
he pulled you cannot hate on the guy
isn't he isn't he pretty tall too is he
like no I don't know I just know he
pulls like he he just digs pulling or
pulling pull pull he pulls hot chicks
yeah dude everyone of his wife everyone
was a model except for the original one
but the two wives the original one was
rough yeah
no I think it's because um he he owned
he owned um the the Miss World Pat
beauty pageant thing oh yeah that was
his company oh it's a very Weinstein
approach to it kind of probably yeah
have you ever had any allegations
regarding those things just Stormy
Daniels
oh yeah yeah that was the big one yeah
yeah and then he sued her because it
wasn't that NDA held up yeah so that
ended with her being in the losing yeah
because she broke an NDA damn he's a gay
that's wild
but you know you don't drink or nothing
you don't do [ __ ] I think the only thing
he's addicted to his [ __ ] but even then
you don't even know because I don't
think Millennia is getting her pucking I
don't think she's getting [ __ ] right
oh yeah why because there's all those
clips of like Trump trying to hold her
hand she goes get your [ __ ] hand yeah
walking down the [ __ ] [ __ ] if he was
hitting around she'd like hold here it's
like she's all like no I can't let him
go his dick is too good where's Melania
from for Slovakia or something they just
don't do PDA out there that's all good
yeah she's a presidential woman now she
uh well she was she's like inappropriate
I [ __ ] you later nothing in front of
public
this is not Christian like
there's all those footages where like
they're sitting together and I will try
to do like like that thing and she's
like get the [ __ ] away you know and then
that was the funniest compilation though
there's no way Trump [ __ ] well though
you know like you think he's a generous
lover no way
he takes he takes bro he's not he's not
giving you can use orange everywhere
else he's that dude he's not doing
Bart's technique with the fingernails on
the thighs
you don't do that
that's a Bart original you think he's
stealing you're moving hey that's a
man-to-man technique though that's not a
that's not for girls I don't think he's
I don't think he even
with these [ __ ] hell no I think Biden
eats everything else you yeah I think
Biden I think Biden is probably a
cunnilingus expert this is a very very
important topic yes is he who eats [ __ ]
more Trump have you seen what Biden
looked like when he was young that fool
looks like all he did was eat ass he
he's probably a giver somebody that
looks like all they did was eat it
just wants to smell [ __ ] that's true
but you know if he wants to smell it
he's probably gonna eat it what did I
say about the guy I think he he looks
like he smells it and he jacks off to it
but he's like one of those like hey
that's our president dude
and then leaves yeah but I just got he
was a handsome Feller back that's what
I'm saying he's
probably if you look at his younger
years he looks he doesn't look the same
guy he looks so different you guys don't
think he's a handsome bro he was
snorting ass I think it's because I've
seen too many certain cheeks
I'm [ __ ] smelling children yeah he
does smell he does he's a smeller yeah
he sniffed that girl that little girl
she was singing in choir he sniffed her
yeah that's one right here yeah he's not
younger dude that's Better Call Saul
this is Nicholas Cage this one yeah he's
kind of oh that's handsome yeah bang
bang right there
black and white huh I liked it when
Trump was cool like like when he was
grabbing [ __ ] and it was like
pre-president Trump like The Apprentice
Trump like when all the rappers all the
rappers used to be like oh [ __ ]
Donald Trump he's cool he's one of us
and then after he became president that
there's that whole song like [ __ ] Donald
Trump [ __ ] don't remember so it's like
once you become president or political I
think people hate you like same [ __ ]
happened to Arnold but Kodak Black [ __ ]
with Donald Trump he said he calls him
his Gemini Twins
and Kanye likes Donald Trump too Lil
Wayne Kanye likes everything wrong
though right I don't think Donald Trump
likes him back though Kanye
who's that Trump that is Trump that was
a good Christian boy he don't eat [ __ ]
look at that he just smell it no no
that's Donald Trump he looks creepier
bro he looks hella creepy damn that's
crazy yo Donald I'm telling you man from
if a man does not like drink or do drugs
or anything his sexual style is vanilla
too you think he doesn't eat [ __ ] he
[ __ ] vomited after he did anal like
come on yeah
see he's not an intimate lover no no
holding hands no I don't like any of
that [ __ ] inappropriate it's all gay to
me
I'm a man's man that's what I thought
dude I keep my kisses blown yeah
there's some distance between them
so can you imagine a couple they're like
no no that lip touching [ __ ] that's all
we do
what's crazy is uh there's definitely
people that are going to Twitter now
that are very obviously upset uh with
the fact that this guy's doing nfts
especially since back in 2009 he was the
guy who was talking about how he didn't
trust or like things like Bitcoin and
crypto cryptocurrency I also think he's
dropping [ __ ] at the wrong time
no but he's not dropping it I think to
to sell anything he's dropping it to get
his name out there because he's running
for it yeah it's a market dude he does
have a crazy fan base yeah right he does
he might as well just come out with
regular trading cards and that's
probably gonna fund his campaign we go
crazy over him to win up to win a
sweepstakes to go to the gala but even
his fans are mad about that because his
fans are not nft type people nah one 99
bucks is definitely a lot more
affordable but they sold out like the
first year really they sold out yeah
they sold out already and he made 45
000 total nfts with a per buyer limit of
100. 35 000 45 000 45 000 each one of
them was 50 bucks 100 bucks wow
so how much is that is that for 450
let's see well that's good numbers
that's chump change for a guy like Biden
no no no no no each one's 100 bucks so
4.5 that's 4 million yeah 4.5 million
that's good man well that's right it's
not it's not 10 bucks it's more for the
marketing too like I said because he's
running for president
you guys got to release some nfts but
not everybody who buys that would
necessarily vote for it and that's the
thing some people do it for the memes
yeah that's true it's not 100 meme man
I'm down for someone to help me my ass
because DeSantis is still ahead of them
right in the polls yeah the Santa's got
no nmts not yet he's like the sensible
Trump I like him people like the Santa's
because it's like DeSantis isn't gonna
split the country up but he's gonna do
some [ __ ] more like yeah yeah he's
gonna be smarter instead of like who's
the the santis on the other side is
there one oh the Liberals yeah is there
like news of Newsome Newsome
the other two was like bashing each
other right now so Newsome hasn't made
an announcement but of course DeSantis
has but he might
I don't know if Biden's gonna be able to
last another debate dude they might
sneeze and fall apart that's just
everyone's like I don't understand what
you're saying anymore how old is he now
it's like 600. they got him walking the
wrong direction so many times dude
imagine if that was your grandpa yeah
you know what I mean you'd be like dude
like there's one through he's like this
we're supposed to shake someone's hand
it goes like this
and then the other guy's like bro I'm
Secret Service like go that way
I just love that they never acknowledge
like how did
how do they never acknowledge that [ __ ]
I don't know what you're talking about
right he starts smelling the Secret
Service the only reason why I want Trump
to make it to the end is I want to see
him roast but I just want to see that
interaction because all the other
presidents aren't gonna [ __ ] stoop to
that level that's true yeah they're all
gonna be like clean political they're
gonna play it safe they're gonna be safe
right but you [ __ ] know that Trump is
gonna go out there and call out that
Cena [ __ ] and he's gonna [ __ ] bully
him there yeah so I was like people no
punches because it's crazy that's
assault let's get Biden and [ __ ]
Trump all while and out [ __ ] [ __ ]
freestyle
that's where the presidential baseball
that's where it should be yeah and the
Nick Cannon's like yeah that was fire
yeah while he holds his other kid yeah
yeah yeah yeah kid number like 43 yeah
dude baby mommy how do you see the the
meme of him like when he does FaceTime
with his kids it's just like a monitors
oh yeah yeah it's like a zoom classroom
call it's a zoom call it was hilarious
you guys see Diddy's new Vietnamese
chick yeah it's like what the hell that
dude I know lucky girl man [ __ ] what do
you mean he has a girl from Vietnam no
no she lives in Orange County but she's
Vietnamese I was on the low low and she
had a kid with her yeah
[Music]
I think that's out there to like kind of
nullify her like hey he's not gay oh
people are calling them gay oh they were
or like because I think some some people
release stuff about him being gay or
bisexual I think that just it's like a
you hold those bullets in your pocket
you think okay here's a chick poop what
city was she from uh I don't know Garden
Grove it's Orange County though because
there's a guard girl he's still gay
because you know she's the man in the
relationship
[Music]